what's your favorite rick and morty
concept uh
just to spring that on you is there
there's a lot of sort of scientific
engineering ideas explored there there's
the favorite one that's the butter robot
it's great to yeah it's a great show
yeah dragon ball is awesome
somebody that's exactly like you from an
alternate dimension showed up there elon
tusk
yeah that's right that you voiced yeah
rick morty suddenly explores a lot of
interesting concepts
uh so like what's your favorite one i
know the butter robot suddenly is uh
you know it's like it it's certainly
possible to have too much sentience in a
device
um like you don't have your toast to be
like
a super genius toaster it's gonna hate
hate life because all i could just make
is toast but if you know it's like you
don't want to have like super intel just
stuck in a
very limited device um do you think it's
too easy from if we talk about from the
engineering perspective of super
intelligence like with marvin the robot
like is it
it seems like it might be very easy to
engineer just a depressed robot
like it sure it's not obvious to
engineer a robot that's going to
find a fulfilling existence same as
humans i suppose
but
i wonder if that's like the default
if you don't do a good job on building a
robot it's going to be sad a lot
well we can reprogram robots easier than
we can reprogram humans
so
i guess if you let it evolve
without
tinkering then it might get sad
but you can change the optimization
function
and have it be a cheery robot
you